>> Sean: JUST 133 DAYS TO GO
UNTIL YOU BECOME THE ULTIMATE
JERRY AND YOU MAKE THE ULTIMATE
DECISION.
BIDEN SEEMS CONTENT TO CAMPAIGN
SLOWLY ALONE IN HIS BASEMENT
BUNKER INDEFINITELY.
THERE WITH REACTION TO THIS AND
MUCH MORE, DALLAS MAVERICKS
OWNER, SHARK TANK, I LOVE THE
SHOW, I LOVE ENTREPRENEURIALISM
AND MARK CUBAN IS BACK WITH US.
SO YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT CHARM,
BUT ON THE PROGRAM A COUPLE OF
TIMES AND I WANT TO TALK TO
ABOUT BIDEN.
FIRST QUESTION, DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT HE HAS THE STRENGTH, THE
STAMINA, THE MENTAL ACUITY, THE
ALERTNESS TO BE TAKING ON WHAT
IS THE TOUGHEST JOB IN THE
WORLD, BEING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, DO YOU AND
YOUR HEART BELIEVE HE DOES?
>> 100%, ABSOLUTELY, NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN’T WANT TO RUN
A COUNTRY.
HE WANTS TO RUN A CAMPAIGN.
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY WANTS TO RUN
A COUNTRY.
>> Sean: GIVE ME A
BUMPER STICKER.
DID A LOT OF GOOD THINGS.
HERE’S MY NEXT QUESTION.
TALKING ABOUT PREDATORS IN ’94,
DONALD TRUMP IS THE ONE THAT
THEY’D CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
PRISON REFORM.
DONALD TRUMP DID OPPORTUNITY
ZONES, NOT JOE OR BARACK.
DONALD TRUMP GAVE A RECORD LOW
AFTER RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
FOR EVERY MINORITY GROUP IN THE
COUNTRY, NOT JOE AND NOT BARACK.
MY QUESTION IS THAT’S ALL FACT.
>> YOU GAVE ME THE BUMPER
STICKERS.
>> Sean: THOSE ARE FACTS.
>> THAT’S FAIR.
YOU COULD SAY THE EXACT SAME
THING ABOUT EVERY SINGLE
REPUBLICAN SENATOR RIGHT THIS
MOMENT.
>> Sean: BUT THEY ARE NOT
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
I’M ASKING YOU THIS, JOE HAS
BEEN IN OFFICE 50 YEARS.
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT EIGHT
YEARS.
TRUMPETED THAT, NOT JOE.
SO TELL ME -- HERE’S THE
QUESTION.
TELL ME WHAT JOE HAS DONE THAT
YOU WERE PROUD OF THAT QUALIFIES
HIM TO BE PRESIDENT AFTER 50
YEARS.
>> I DON’T KNOW.
>> Sean: HE WAS YOUR
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> IT’S A PROBLEM FOR ALL
SENATORS.
THE QUESTION YOU ASK WHEN YOU
VOTE FOR SOMEBODY IS WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO -- >> Sean: HE
WAS VICE PRESIDENT.
HE HAD EIGHT YEARS.
>> OKAY, HE WAS A BIG PART OF
OBAMACARE, THE ACA.
HERE WE ARE, YOU’VE GOT MILLIONS
IF NOT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR EMPLOYER’S
INSURANCE.
DONALD TRUMP HAS NOT SAID A WORD
WORD.
NOT ONLY HAS HE NOT SAID A WORD
ABOUT HEALTH CARE, HE IS LOOKING
TO END THE ACA WITH NO
REPLACEMENT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
THEN.
IS IMPORTANT.
I REALLY WANT AN ANSWER.
SO WHEN EIGHT YEARS, THE
OBAMA-BIDEN RECORD IS 13 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS,
8 MILLION MORE IN POVERTY, THE
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION RATES
SINCE THE ’70s, AND
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD PRECORONA,
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS FACT,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
HE’S ONLY BEEN IN OFFICE LESS
THAN FOUR YEARS.
>> OBAMA AND BIDEN, THEY TOOK
OVER AFTER A REALLY BAD
RECESSION AND GREW THE ECONOMY
CONTINUOUSLY, BUT WHEN THEY HAD
A PROBLEM TO SOLVE WHICH WAS THE
GREAT RECESSION 12 YEARS AGO,
THEY SOLVED IT.
NOW WHERE ARE WE NOW?
WE ARE NOT HOLDING IT.
WE ARE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> Sean: WE JUST HAD TO WAIT A
HALF MILLION NEW JOBS AND A
RECORD RETAIL SALES IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP DID THAT, NOT
BIDEN.
IN THE BASEMENT.
>> IS LIKE I EXPLAINED IT TO MY
KIDS, WHEN YOUR BANK ACCOUNT
GOES FROM $10 TO $1, THEN IT
GOES TO 2, YOU CAN SAY YOU’VE
DOUBLED YOUR BANK ACCOUNT BUT
YOU WERE STILL DOWN 80%.
OF >> Sean: BUT THEY PREDICTED
NINE AND A HALF MILLION JOBS
LOST.
WE GAVE TWO AND A HALF MILLION.
NOW I DIDN’T THINK THAT WOULD
HAPPEN UNTIL AUGUST.
I NEVER SAW 18% IN RETAIL SALES.
>> NO, AND THAT’S WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT ENTREPRENEURS.
THEY ARE THE BACKBONE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE.
>> I KNOW JEFF, JOE BIDEN
BELIEVES IN ENTREPRENEURSHIP
BECAUSE I WENT TO A WHITE HOUSE
EVENT THAT HE SPOKE ABOUT WHITE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD HE DO WHEN
EIGHT YEARS, TELL ME THE BIGGEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT IN EIGHT YEARS,
TELL ME.
THE BIGGEST ACCOMPLISHMENT.
WHAT IS IT?
>> I THINK THE ACA IS EASILY
THEIR BIGGEST ACCOMPLISHMENT AND
IT’S UNFORTUNATE THEY ARE TRYING
TO DISMANTLE IT, AND I WILL ALSO
SAY I’LL GO BACK TO WHAT I JUST
SAID, THE ONE EVENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT JOE BIDEN PUT
ON AND SPOKE ABOUT HIS SUPPORT
FOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS MORE
THAN HE HAS EVER DONE FOR
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
SO IF YOU WERE TO GO IN -- I
KIND OF ADMIRE YOU BECAUSE I
LOVE YOU ARE OUTSPOKEN, I LOVE
THAT YOU LIKE ENTREPRENEURS, I
THINK YOUR POLITICS ARE NUTS,
BUT HAVING A HARD TIME DEFENDING
BIDEN’S RECORD.
HERE’S WHAT I WILL CHALLENGE
YOU.
I’LL GIVE YOU TIME TO DO YOUR
RESEARCH.
I WILL INVITE YOU BACK ON THE
SHOW, AND YOU TELL ME THE GREAT
RECORD OF JOE BIDEN IN THE LAST
50 YEARS.
IS THAT A DEAL?
YOU KEEP SAYING THAT.
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> HE COULD COME UP WITH THE
CURE FOR THE COMMON COLD AS A
SENATOR.
>> Sean: OF DONALD TRUMP CURE
CANCER, PEOPLE WOULD HATE HIM.